[Music]
seeing that you're about to see is taken
from Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
the reason we shot it with the IMAX
cameras because it really just magnifies
the experience and makes the world more
vivid and real not to mention the fact
that just the scope and scale of that
world shooting an IMAX in big 143 really
gives you that feeling of just like
being surrounded by image good yeah we
got it Zack likes to move the camera a
lot we pushed the limits for sure crazy
dolly shots Technic range shots even
hand hill with the IMAX I wasn't sure it
could be done but we did it you know you
take this camera that you know really is
designed for nature photography it is
fun to just watch the world that you can
create with it there's a particular
sequence that's a one single take it was
really complicated but it was certainly
worth it because what you get is just
this epic scale the kinds of shots we
made with the camera we certainly were
amplified once you see Batman and
Superman standing looking at each other
in a movie now anything's possible
let's face it the two biggest names in
superhero dumb this is the sort of Alpha
and Omega of this world is gonna be
quite the event I believe I'm I'm
excited
you
you